[Musica]
alla fine [ __ ] va capito bella
tutte le ansie benvenuti a questo
momento sono fa dj ed oggi siamo su
mente memorizzati nei tre ragazzi dalla
beta di undead che era uscita circa un
anno fa è stato il primo videogame che
ho registrato sul canale il primo video
esatte che cazzo ti trovi mi sono venuti
sin dall'inizio
comunque va bene andiamo avanti ad ogni
episodio perché ci sono tantissimi
soltanto che hanno messo per ora
soltanto il primo out e quindi direi che
possiamo fare questo che già sarà un
casino easy norma l'anno paranormal
ovviamente ragazzi paranormal non posso
pensare bifaro non rendere in modalità
poppante ragazzi questa è la modalità
mia l'hanno fatta apposta per me perché
sono troppo prosa che tanto faccio due
passi e per quello meno mette nei caf
ranzi come si deve ma fa niente o al q2
il pivot cup in appreso have never seen
before cosa faresti se ti svegliassi in
un posto dove non sei mai stato prima
come dissi nel primo episodio di sicuro
mi metterei cercare pagine ma come
presentimento che stiamo prenderà fare
proprio quello io cos'è questo posto e
la casa della nonna amico mio stiamo per
andare a portare il cestino della
merenda si vedrà anche le braccia che
bello ce l'hanno l'anno migliorato un
casino raga non vedo l'ora di vedere che
cazzo è cambiato è perché ho scelto
paranormal ma porca [ __ ] quanto sono
i viola di lav ritmo scelto perché
volevo fare il figo però so già che
tanto benevento non va liscio il bis in
iraq qualcuno deve essere vicino
sì perché ha lasciato una vacanza la
torcia perché si prende cazzo qui a
reset ufita 1 cent amico mio
dato che la macchina accesa perché non
ti levi dai [ __ ] come si deve nove
erano
farai mai lo so lei come cazzo facciata
gialla foggia ha preso fatta non so come
ma c'è perfetto viene che possiamo
avventurarci nel paese delle meraviglie
come si deve e tanto minuti ok che
cos'era
non lo so mi co mio ma non farti troppe
domande perché non sarà la prima volta
che lo vedrà in sé è un mio amico poi te
lo presento non ti preoccupare molto
simpatico è che cos'è sta roba presse è
tubitak no bene invece dei tornado dopo
il veloce della generazione perfetto ma
che è sta roba la cava si è spiaggiato
un piccione sul cartellone
vabbé non fa nulla lasciamo perdere
andiamo avanti ragazzi sono
contentissimo di fare una scampagnata
come ai vecchi tempi non avete idea
tra l'altro poi pieno di b camion di
macchine deragliate non si sa perché i
ragazzi lo slider meno un pericolo
pubblico comunque la cosa che non ho mai
capito
e come mai ogni singolo slider man devi
accendere il generatore c'è mio di 8
ragazzi dobbiamo vederla in questo modo
lo slider me nel nemico degli
elettricisti in poche parole va beh son
dei bot
ci sono dei boiler bellissimi ragazzi
questo è il secondo parco giochi più
famoso al mondo cioè potete vedere con
tempismo perfetto ragazzi sono ci siamo
ho trovato la porta
aprite sta roba per favore fatemi capire
che un dio va bene va bene chiusa
tranquilli va benissimo se chiusa non
importa
andrò da un'altra parte non ho problemi
c'è io gli ho detto di entrare molto
cordialmente questa è l'accoglienza ma
[ __ ]
e cos'è sta roba c'è una una baracca
bellissima non c'è anche non troppo nel
caso anche l'hanno fatta a fare c'è un
qualcosa di rosso non so che cos'è ma io
vado a prenderlo perché mi piace far
casino ragazzi non ho idea di che cosa
sia sta roba ma di sicuro non è niente
di buono ma noi lo premiamo perché a me
piace
premere il pulsante che non so che cazzo
so penso che non ci sia la del gas nella
valvola non mettere del gas qua dentro
nel caso trovo gli altri che ne so io
non solo mio dio mi fate fare
l'elettricista al benzinaio decidete voi
non lo so ma para che devo trovare una
tanica di benzina non chiedetevi perché
cioè non chiedetemi a cosa serve quel
punto ha forse il generatore forse era
quello generatore effettivamente non lo
so comunque devo trovare una tanica di
benzina
vi ricordo che c'era una casa dove cazzo
siamo intanto stiamo andando nella carpi
avanti c'è una caverna penso sia quel
mio dio che bella ragazza è fantastico
non vedevo l'ora di arrivare in st
caverna perché mi ispira fiducia e di
sicuro non mi mette la paura vero ecco
cos'è c'è un bullo madonna di questo
buglione nel gigante di ferro mio dio
cioè è un trust in trasformers ha perso
un bullone mi sa proprio facciamo in
finta di niente andiamo partitone ieri
come faccio a portarlo quel bullone
penso che nelle mutande non ci stia
non quindi non idea di dove solo sia
messo comunque ha forse capito
[Musica]
si è chiusa pure questa pure questa
ragazzi non so dove cazzo stiamo andando
ma è tutto cos'è chiavi mio dio ho
trovato delle chiami mi sembra
impossibile
ho trovato un oggetto che serve ha
intenzione di aprire o no è chiuso
facendo alla mia vita pista porta a
buttare ok va bene non fa niente vieni
caratù la chiave non è lesto stronzo
ragazzi non posso continuare così che
vede temi che sto diventando esaurito
mio dio non posso andare da nessuna
parte che c'è quel demente come senso di
aprire una cazzo di porta c'è quel
deficiente che se non si mette in mezzo
non è contento così essa strada tra
l'altro è babbo non so dove stiamo
andando però stiamo salendo scale
inutili alla fine voglio un lecca lecca
e cos'è sta merda che non era così in
aprile la prima volta che l'ho vista
no perché sta roba qua c'era anche nel
primo nella beta con la cavo giocato la
prima volta ma non era così alta porca
[ __ ]
vabbè tentiamo di salire prima che quel
tizio arrivi e me lo metta nel ca pranzi
per ora che ci mettono mezz'ora a salire
sta roba quindi a un faccio un tutorial
su come dimagrire di 280 kg in una sola
salita oppure taglio fino alla fine
ma quanto cazzato sta a fare mezz'ora
che vado avanti
il dito che lo devo amputare ca ok ci
siamo cioè non c'è ragazzi il dito mi
sta chiedendo pietà che cazzo ci fa un
divano sopra una [ __ ] torre di 350
metri e soprattutto come cazzo se non
l'ho portato c'è chi chi chi è che se
portato un divano su sta merda di torre
chi è chi è il pazzo maniaco che è una
new entry poteva scrivere quel mio nome
ascensore grazie perfetto ragazzi sono
ricordano sicuri che se lo ricordano
cosa è servito salire qua sopra c'è un
divano ragazzi così guardiamo the
walking dead
non perché manca al televisore luce
nulla ragazzi dobbiamo tornare giù
dobbiamo tornare in più moderna mio dio
basta non lo farò mai più mai più
dov'è la torre e mm caduta la torcia da
qualche parte non c'è più si sa ragazzi
troviamo si passi che non si sa che se
all e un'ascia dove tira scordi amico
mio ok brutto vieni qua vieni che c'è fa
vj con l'ascia vieni qua non si fa
indietro guarda che non scherzo questa
taglia medico che sta riducendo in
bottiglia sto legno recarsi non fa un
cazzo stage abbi cura di me aviv vedete
come spaventato è spaventatissimo è
spaventatissimo non ne può più
non si scherza con fa vj quando c'è un
ascia fronte ragazzi perché è ok ok ok
va bene allora sia sto scherzando va
bene lascia non taglia te ne sei accorto
anche tu che ne dici se io vado a
tagliare legna e tu speri generatori
così si è seduto a pastiglia nessuno gli
è piaciuta l'idea perfetta ragazzi è che
quando si parla di spegnere i generatori
lui è sempre il primo ci sono due
cosmico trilli è un orangotango un
grande brutos lander un po vj che corre
il gatto il topo jack the killer non
manca più nessuno
se spunta anche pippo mica go addosso
ragazzi non ce la faremo mai cioè quel
pezzente di merda robusta basta che
cazzo vuoi ragazzi se mi spunta un'altra
volta che la fico nell'occhio perché mi
sono rotto le palle ed ai c'è tanta
gente nel mondo che cazzo vuoi da me
ma poi cosa mi serve stage ap non ho
ancora capito mio dio mio dio
l'illuminazione l'illuminazione ragazzi
non ci posso allora non è vero che non
taglia proprio un cazzo hai visto devi
cominciare ad aver paura amico mio
perché servito a qualcosa cosa c'è qua
dentro niente e alla fine ho sfondato
soltanto sta roba ma non c'è nulla
no no no no no ho trovato le chiavi ho
trovato le chiavi
ho tolto le chiavi ma che si arriva il
più alzo mio dio facciamo così rosea la
cantilena cosa che funziona sempre
ok chiudi gli occhi se ti guarda fa vj
significa che non ci sei
la fanciulla non funziona se ti guardavo
vj silvia che non ci sei ok alla seconda
funzionato miur viola prima no la
seconda si vede che non aveva sentito
bene ragazzi ma con due miliardi di
chiavi ma ce ne sarà una che funziona
vero una sola no non lo chiedo per
sicurezza e non perché siamo qua che
girano da mezz'ora c'è cazzo pensavo
l'avessero torta sta a casa ma
evidentemente erano soltanto spostata
bene così permesso c'è qualcuno e di
chiavi che chiusa anche questa no è
questa aperta perfetto ma l'hanno legata
che figura le zanzariere per non far
passare le zanzare anche mio zio non ci
sarà l'ex lander iere per caso noi
ragazzi siamo in cucina non c'è il frigo
però io cerco soltanto una cosa no non
lo dico non vi dà soddisfazione mi
spiace ragazzi un qualcosa di utile
vista casa ci sarà pure non è che l'han
fatta per caso cos'è
è un momento che verrà ricordato nei
secoli
ho trovato la pistola islanda e adesso
vediamo se si caga addosso quel fetente
di merda 3153 non so che cazzo sia me lo
ricordo vero c'è anche qui
cos'è to me c'è stato perché ragazzi che
è successo dove dove la mia pistola dove
la pistola maledizione si svende rino 36
che voglio giocare soltanto vieni qui
adesso si nasconde quel lurido dov'è
dove comunque 3153 me lo devo ricordare
perché non sta scritto da nessuna parte
anche se non so che cosa serve a
qualcosa servirà per forza se no non
l'ho scriverebbero ok ok ok tutti calmi
dop affanculo non spara spara vale detto
spara non muore
non si può succedere
ci crederò mai va bene che tanto salvato
la partita concludo qui l'episodio per
oggi con che ragazzi 6 video è piaciuto
come al solito è stato argomento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
non gli video trovate nella descrizione
sarà il senatur iscritti scrivete che
noi ci vediamo un prossimo vito beh
ragazzi